[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue
et bonne chose c'est sa masse avait des
logements abordables entre trois et demi
et cat ennemis
lucie charland est de retour à fismes
ski après y avoir vécu 25 ans
avec ses modestes revenus elle doit
trouver pour le 1er juillet 700 chanter
15 par mois internet compris
ok c'est un trois et demi un appartement
assez grand pour accueillir son fils de
16 ans une fin de semaine sur deux
bonjour teinte inera on a bientôt le
chat cooking mans que ce que c'est c'est
mon futur qui se planquent lola s'est
mis au service des aides à la recherche
de logement rimouski on tente tant bien
que mal d'aider les locataires qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver un toit pour la
propriétaire le rejet par nice matin et
devrait rappeler et comme le taux
d'inoccupation et de 0,2 pour cent la
tâche est ardue pour la petite équipe
mise sur pied il ya un an le prix que je
vois c'est en 1215 hommes pour hibou
logements qui sont assez grandes sinon
manche à la majeure partie de mon temps
et de mon travail c'est pas son
téléphone à parler avec des gens qui se
cherchent un logement puis je regarde
avec eux pour différentes solutions
c'est pas on va appeler au service
d'haïti qui vont nous trouver un
logement il n'y a pas assez de logements
donc on peut juste les mettre en contact
avec les propriétaires on leur donnait
des lésés
[Musique]
ouais daniel ouais c'est ça on a
peut-être une nouvelle station l'urgence
l'enjeu pour baladeurs et des
basculements pour les gens qui est bien
moins de capacité financière où les gens
qui avaient un historique ma vérité
arbitres mais là ça va on a des gens qui
sont des fois des coupes sont sous lé
marché travail les deux donc on parle de
personnes qui ont dépassé financière
on va construire de
capello d'ici deux trois semaines pour
éviter que des familles se retrouvent à
la rue lepic d'habitation de la région
transforme les unités de dépannage en
logements d'urgence suffisamment grand
pour accueillir des familles qui
pourront y rester pour une période
maximale de trois mois le gros souper
sont eux aussi qu'ils vont savoir des
grandes familles qu'il était en grosse
difficulté ont délogé dans un studio un
exemple donc à ce moment lorsqu'on a
fait ce qu'on a encore des cats et demi
en logements qui ont pour accueillir des
familles même moins depuis 98 paraissait
que j'ai jamais eu une crise du logement
demain moi non plus après avoir épluché
des annonces depuis des mois le
découragement du si est palpable au
point où c'est elle qui nous a
interpellé dans la rue lorsqu'elle était
en voiture avec son ami je sais que
beaucoup d'eau
à un peu moins d'une centaine de
kilomètres de l'oeuvre légion de matane
le taux d'inoccupation est un peu moins
dramatique 1,7 pour cent
une génération black hat et nice était
petit sylvain dubé le coordonnateur du
comité logement de matane qui existe
depuis moins d'un an j'imagine
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui se retrouvent
dans 40 ans un gardien avec un ennemi où
elle chante portugais dans cette région
plus habituée un effet de rareté aussi
marqué votre moteur il informe les
locataires de leurs droits il les
accompagne aussi parfois jusque devant
le tribunal administratif du logement
c'est pour une période facile c'est
ainsi bon il nous fait rencontrer ce
locataire qui vit dans un logement ou
des travaux tardent à être réalisée par
le propriétaire pour nettoyer un dégât
d'eau qui ont le plus de difficulté à se
trouver un logement en ce moment sur les
taux n'est savoir que la moitié du monde
qui viennent me voir c'est des gens de
la classe moyenne comme en plus je vous
ai vu des gens que je vois sur 50 à 60
75 % de leur revenu pour avoir un toit
alors si on les aide pas on veut tous
payer factures auquel vous allez perdre
cauchemar
cette année ils vont réellement avoir
des ménages des familles qui auront pas
de logement le 1er juillet
[Musique]
une qualité de vie ici à matane où on
est à cinq minutes de tout ça devient
intéressant pour des gens qui aiment le
plein air la région a attiré de nombreux
nouveaux résidents pendant la pandémie
mais les logements sont insuffisants
pour répondre à la demande la ville a
adopté plusieurs incitatifs pour
stimuler la construction mais la
création de nouvelles unités prend du
temps beaucoup de temps si on part à
zéro je dirais peut-être un 1 ou 2
est-ce qu'ils pourraient avoir certains
mécanismes des gouvernements pour
épauler les différents dépassement des
coûts de construction
ça serait une belle réponse apportée
à la fin du mois de mai québec annoncé
le versement de 60 18 millions de
dollars pour répondre à l'actuelle crise
du logement la province devront
notamment des centaines de ménages qui
ont un appartement non subventionnées à
payer leur loyer la somme servira aussi
à quilly de l'hébergement temporaire
d'urgence et est ce que ce sera
suffisant
moi je parle là pour tout le monde qui
en recherche de logement des gens qui
sont poignets chez leur père leur mère
avec les enfants qui ont même pas les
moyens de se payer mes pièces de
logements même s'ils travaillent même si
drogba et au salaire minimum ils sont
nombreux comme elle a espéré que l'accès
au logement devienne un enjeu électoral
cet automne
[Musique]